[Musik]
chaotische lage am flughafen in kabul
tausende menschen versuchen weiter in
eins der rettende flugzeuges zu gelangen
wie weiter in dem teils
lebensbedrohlichen konflikt darüber
haben heute die staats und
regierungschefs der sieben großen
industriestaaten die g-7 in einem
digitalen sondergipfel beraten darunter
auch kanzlerin merkel
die
evakuierungsaktion erfolgt in großer
gemeinsamkeit natürlich das will ich
noch einmal betonen haben die
vereinigten staaten von amerika hier die
führung ohne die vereinigten staaten von
amerika können wir zum beispiel die
anderen die
evakuierungsaktion nicht weiterführen
das muss man ganz klar wissen guten
abend willkommen zum zdf spezial für die
menschen in afghanistan spitzt sich die
lage dramatisch zu die usa haben heute
entschieden dass sie nicht länger als
bis zum 31.08 in afghanistan bleiben
wollen eine verlängerung der luftbrücke
wird es also nicht geben viele fürchten
jetzt racheaktionen der taliban gegen
alle die für die regierung in kabul
gearbeitet haben gegen alle auch die mit
dem westen kooperiert haben in den
wirren dieser tage ist manchen die
flucht geglückt andere sitzen mit ihren
familien fest und trauen sich nicht mehr
auf die straße patricia schäfer
berichtet
die lage in kabul wird immer
verzweifelter ein taliban sprecher
kündigte heute an eigene landsleute
nicht mehr zum flughafen durchzulassen
niederschmetternden nachrichten für
menschen wie den jungen familienvater
den wir heute am frühen abend in kabul
erreichen er hat für internationale
entwicklungs projekte gearbeitet und
muss nun um das leben seiner familie mit
zwei kindern fürchten
die zeit läuft aus leute wie wir die
berechtigt wären afghanistan zu
verlassen und das auch unbedingt tun
müssen haben keine chance zum flughafen
zu kommen weil sie riskieren von den
taliban gefasst zu werden
um den jungen akademiker zu schützen
haben wir in unkenntlich gemacht seinen
namen und seine stimme verändert ich bin
jetzt bereits mehrfach umgezogen denn
die leute kennen mich in vielen
provinzen sie kennen mich gut und ich
weiß nicht welche informationen über
mich sie weitergeben
[Musik]
eine gruppe um die münchner künstlerin
mubaraks die seit fast 30 jahren in
deutschland lebt versucht zu helfen wo
es geht und hat kontakt zu vielen
ausreisewilligen
von menschen auch sich eingesetzt haben
viele künstler viele journalisten
fehler wirklich die die an diese
demokratie und frauenrechte und
menschenrechte geglaubt haben von
gestern auf heute wurden so viele
menschen aus kabul ausgeflogen wie noch
nie seit der machtübernahme der taliban
21.600 binnen 24 stunden doch das
zeitfenster schließt sich es ist völlig
unklar ob side und seine familie es noch
schaffen
es ist nicht nur schockierend sondern
wir fragen uns mit großer sorge was
passiert als nächstes
[Musik]
und aus südtirol ist uns der potsdamer
militärhistoriker sönke neitzel
zugeschaltet guten abend
ziel genannt das letzte kapitel im
nato-einsatz afghanistan steht unter dem
ungeschriebenen motto rette sich wer
kann was ist da vorher so schief
gelaufen dass es jetzt zu diesem
unrühmlichen ende kommt
naja der afghanistan einsatz war
sicherlich viel zu
überambitioniert von deutschland vom
westen und hat vor allen dingen der
logik gar nicht afghanistans gehorcht
sondern vielmehr der logik was kann man
innenpolitisch verkaufen wie kann man
diesen einsatz der ja sehr umstritten
war von anfang an innenpolitisch
attraktiver machen und das war
sicherlich ein grund strukturfehler
dieser operation der 31 august ist genau
in einer woche und seit einer stunde
etwa wissen wir dass bleibt das
abzugsdatum
welche möglichkeiten hat denn danach die
bundesregierung noch
die bundesregierung muss versuchen die
nördlichen nachbarländern also
tadschikistan usbekistan turkmenistan zu
unterstützen falls flüchtlinge aus dem
norden afghanistans wo die bundeswehr
stationiert war es schaffen über die
grenze zu kommen und da muss man
sicherlich entwicklungshilfe leisten
muss lager aufbauen kann dann versuchen
flüchtlinge von dort aus auszuführen auf
bildern sehen wir taliban bis an die
zähne bewaffnet auf amerikanischen
humvees der westen hat ja nicht nur
verloren er hat auch seine feinde
ausgerüstet wie gefährlich ist das
also die taliban haben in der tat viele
waffen der afghanischen nationalarmee
erbeutet die mit amerikanern und
ausgerüstet war aber ich würde nehmen
keinen so große bedeutung beimisst denn
auch haben wir es müssen gewartet werden
das ist daran ist ja auch zum teil
hightech was sie erarbeitet haben in
diese möglichkeiten stehen den taliban
nicht zur verfügung und genug waffen gab
es ohnehin immer daran habe ich nie
gemacht
diese diese beute die sie jetzt gemacht
haben in dieser an ihrer strategischen
bedeutung nicht zu hoch bewerten für
viele gerade auch soldaten aus dem
westen bleibt ja jetzt so das bittere
gefühl all das sei vergebens gewesen
sehen sie das auch so
naja man kann es kurz sagen die
vergebens war sicherlich nicht nicht
vollständig die bundeswehr hat ja
durchaus im kleinen erfolgreich
gearbeitet aber sie hat natürlich einen
großen ihr ziel nicht erreicht und wenn
man es auf der strategischen ebene sie
dann war es vergebens aber wir sollten
nicht vergessen dass afghanistan ein
anderes land geworden ist völlig anders
als 2001 und daran hat auch die
bundeswehr und die bundesrepublik ihren
anteil trotzdem ist der versuch die
demokratie nach afghanistan zu
exportieren gescheitert was folgt daraus
für künftige krisen in denen der westen
seine sicherheitsinteressen berührt
sieht
das wahrscheinlichste ist zunächst dass
es der westen auch deutschland sehr sehr
zurückhaltend sein wird was man sich die
frage stellt na ja wir haben so viele
auslandseinsätze gemacht die gescheitert
sind oder scheinbar gescheitert sind
aber man muss sich man muss
differenzieren einfach nicht wir können
nicht einfach sagen wir beteiligen uns
nirgendwo auch das heraushalten auch die
enthaltung kann schuldig machen siehe
syrien wo der westen nichts oder ganz
wenig gemacht hat also man muss von mal
zu mal denken und die forderung muss es
zumindest intelligenter zu machen und
nicht nur ausschnitte aus einer
innenpolitische logik heraus zu lassen
vielen dank für das gespräch soll
kneissl
sehr gerne
was immer die große politik aus der
jüngsten afghanistan erfahrung macht für
die menschen im land wird die lage immer
schwieriger wie radikal werden die
taliban den alltag auf den kopf stellen
viele menschen sind verunsichert ja
verängstigt es fehlt oft am
lebensnotwendigen das land bleibt
abhängig von internationaler hilfe viele
hilfsorganisationen wollen ihre projekte
vor ort weiter führen tina an recht
berichtet
irgendwie geht das leben weiter hier in
der provinz logar südlich von kabul doch
die hoffnung auf ein normales leben ist
weit weg
einige familien die aus
sicherheitsgründen geflohen sind kommen
zwar zurück aber sie haben große
wirtschaftliche probleme
die situation ist gar nicht gut
behörden und schulen geschlossen das
personal verunsichert die taliban
versuchen sich als macher zu zeigen wie
hier beim straßenbau aber neben all der
unsicherheit und angst fehlt es vor
allem an geld die versorgungslage spitzt
sich zu in einem land das seit
jahrzehnten von internationaler hilfe
abhängig ist da ist es eine gute
nachricht dass die vereinten nationen
mit ihren hilfsorganisationen vor ort
bleiben wollen mit der großen mehrheit
ihrer 300 ausländischen und rund 3.000
einheimischen mitarbeiter die taliban
selbst haben darum gebeten
auch viele der mehr als 150
nichtstaatlichen hilfsorganisationen
wollen weiter im land helfen die
johanniter haben schon vor tagen
getwittert auch jetzt steht unser team
in kabul gemeinsam mit unseren partnern
den menschen zur seite und führt die
projektarbeit ford ebenso wollt wissen
wir bleiben mit über 300 orts kräften
werden wir alles daran setzen die
projekte fortzuführen alle zusammen
haben mehrere tausend mitarbeiter im
land nicht alle wollen bleiben und
helfen viele haben angst und wollen raus
aus afghanistan
doch wer schafft es noch wer darf
überhaupt eine lebenswichtige frage auch
für die mitarbeiter von susanna lipowicz
gründerin der hilfsorganisation
kinderberg um denen zu helfen die am
meisten schutz brauchen mussten die
helfer auch immer wieder gespräche mit
den taliban führen das misstrauen in
ihre friedlichen beteuerungen nun ist
groß viele helfer möchten das land jetzt
verlassen
guten abend frau lee potts
guten abend gehen oder bleiben das ist
jetzt eine ganz schwierige abwägung wir
gehen ihre mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter damit um
eigentlich will jeder aus afghanistan
ging jeder und
jeder hat angst davor
viele mitarbeiter wissen aber dass sie
nicht rauskommen können und dann sagen
sie dann hoffen sie dass wir da bleiben
dass wir ihnen helfen ihre arbeit
fortzuführen weil sie auch wissen dass
sie sehr wichtig sind mit ihrer
ausbildung mit ihren fähigkeiten für das
land aber wenn es um die angst geht
würde jeder gerne gehen haben sie denn
eigentlich eine einschätzung darüber wie
vielerorts kräfte werden afghanistan
über wie viele wir eigentlich reden nach
20 jahren hilfs ansatz gibt es eine
größenordnung
nein das kann man auch nicht abschätzen
weil die frage ist ja bei ist eine orts
kraft bei mir melden sich jetzt menschen
die für mich gearbeitet haben vor zehn
jahren die haben für ein jahr für mich
gearbeitet vor zehn jahren und zeigen
noch einen vergilbten arbeitsvertrag
eine lohnabrechnung und bitten mich dass
ich ihnen jetzt eine mail schreiben
damit sie im flughafen durchkommen weil
sie da schon seit fünf tagen sitzen und
bei uns ist es so wir hatten die größte
anzahl von mitarbeitern im dezember 2012
das waren 5 140 mitarbeiter und mit der
zahl davor und danach hätten wir
ungefähr 700 mal im futter 7 was eine
afghanische familie hat werden es allein
bei uns drei bis viertausend aus 20
jahren und das ist eine kleine
hilfsorganisation
ist dann ja eine zusammenarbeit mit den
taliban nach ihren bisherigen
erfahrungen überhaupt möglich ohne das
wird es ja kaum weitergehen mit den
projekten
wir haben immer mit den taliban arbeiten
müssen wir haben immer mit ihnen reden
müssen das ist so wenn man ins ländliche
afghanistan geht und dort wo sie immer
regiert haben und die tage bahn sind
menschen wie wir und wir haben die
gleichen krankheiten wir haben basis
medizinische gesundheitsstationen und
die bakterien die machen da keinen
unterschied zwischen uns braucht man
taliban europäische frau und wir hatten
aber das know-how und die möglichkeiten
was medizinische projekte umzusetzen
kinder gesund auf die welt bringen und
so konnten wir mit ihnen reden weil wir
etwas hatten und getan haben
gewährleistet haben was ich selber nie
gemacht haben die taliban haben nie ein
funktionierendes gesundheitswesen
aufbauen können und ich denke dass sie
das jetzt auch nicht verlieren möchten
aber
sympathiepunkte wurden da nicht
ausgeteilt sie haben sich aber sehr
lange zeit engagiert um den menschen in
afghanistan zu helfen sie haben es
gerade geschildert fürsten fürchten sie
jetzt dass das alles vergebens war
nein
entwickler das was wir getan haben ist
nicht vergebens weil wir immer
ausgebildet haben wir haben sehr viele
menschen ausgebildet frauen hebammen
krankenschwestern und alles was da in
die köpfe kam ist er drin geblieben und
wir haben vor allem in dieser zeit das
sind 20 jahre das ist eine generation
gezeigt wie wir ticken wie wir leben
welche werte wir wie verkörpern und das
hat immer zuspruch gefunden also die
menschen die jetzt am flughafen sind die
rennen ja nicht von uns weg die
relegations hin und dass wir dort
vermittelt wird also auf jeden fall
etwas übrig bleiben etwas bleiben von
der arbeit die sie geleistet haben das
ist ja mal ein positiver aspekt vielen
dank für das gespräch
dann gehen die
usa und die g7 partner haben sich
letztlich dem druck der taliban gebeugt
keine verlängerung der bezugsfrist über
den 31 august hinaus die luftbrücke zur
evakuierung besonders gefährdeter
menschen endet spätestens mit diesem
termin die zeit danach wird zeigen wie
ernst es den taliban ist mit ihren eher
moderaten tönen vielen dank für ihr
interesse hier geht es gleich weiter mit
den rosenheim cops einen schönen amt und
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]